j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
notre émission volontairement vous le
savez décalé de l'actualité du jour je
propose un gros plan sur les pesticides
peut-on s'en passer comment basculer
vers une agriculture sans produits
phytosanitaire pourra-t-on nourrir près
d'eux 10 milliards d'humains 9 milliards
700 millions selon les prévisions en
2050 grâce à des exploitations 100% bio
avant d'en débattre un exemple celui du
S métola chlore désormais interdit en
France reportage signé Samia de chir
dans le Maine-et-Loire
dans quelques jours Emmanuel Lachaise va
récolter cette parcelle pour y semer du
maïs mais avant il va y répondre un
herbicide sélectif dans ce bidon vous
avez donc la matière active du S métola
clore on y pense produit juste soit
avant le semis soit juste après le semis
et ce qui fait que le maïs aujourd'hui
ça lui permet de pousser sans forcément
avoir une concurrence avec les mauvaises
herbes très utilisé dans les cultures
céréalières se produit étant sursis fin
2024 le S métolé clore sera interdit une
mauvaise nouvelle pour cette agriculteur
car s'il existe d'autres moyens de
désherber les alternatives coûtent plus
cher on pourra utiliser donc des
molécules qu'on appelle pour faire du
désherbage post levé donc une fois que
la culture elle est levée avec des
efficacités moindres
et ce qui nous oblige bien souvent quand
on a des molécules à efficacité moindre
à multiplier le nombre de passages
l'interdiction prochaine du S
métoléchlor découle d'une décision des
autorités sanitaires françaises en
avance sur les autres pays européens
elle a été prise suite à la découverte
de cette substance cancérigène en
quantité trop importante dans les eaux
souterraines et de surface la France
prend cette décision alors que mes
collègues agriculteurs européens ou de
pays tiers non pas la même exigence et
n'auront pas la même exigence dans le
même pas de temps que nous nous allons
l'avoir en France et ça ça s'appelle de
la distorsion de concurrence la
production qui sera faite sur ces
territoires là pourra rentrer en toute
légitimité sur le territoire français
tu vas pouvoir poser avancer doucement
toute façon c'est ça vachement séchée
d'accord 30 km plus loin l'exploitation
de Valérie Lebouc passait à
l'agriculture biologique il y a 5 ans
avec l'aide de son fils il a-t-elle au
tracteur un outil appelé rotoétrie censé
éliminer les germes des indésirables
qui sont en train de
qui sont en train de germer on voit bien
et du coup faut qu'on casse les germes
des adventices sans casser légèrement de
la culture et ça c'est il y a des fois
avant de se convertir et l'agriculture
biologique Valérie le bouquet utilisé
des produits chimiques contenant du S
métolachlor désormais il n'a plus
recours qu'à la mécanique un surplus de
travail sur une culture de printemps il
faut jusqu'à 4 ou 5 passages de la
machine moi aujourd'hui je suis pas prêt
à revenir en arrière sur la bio parce
que
ces produits là me
gênaient on va dire ça comme ça et puis
je crois beaucoup en l'agroécologie qui
va nous amener
des des solutions techniques pour
avancer pour être capable de produire en
respectant l'environnement et
de manière rentable aussi parce que on
est là pour on a une famille à faire
vivre donc voilà donc non je reviens je
reviendrai pas en arrière même si il y a
quelques pics de travail qui sont un peu
plus compliqués à gérer si c'est
céréales sont plus chers à produire son
produit chimiques elles sont aussi
vendues plus cher 900 euros la tonne de
pois chiches soit deux fois plus qu'en
conventionnel
peut-on se passer de pesticides voilà le
thème de notre débat avec Christian wig
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes directeur
scientifique agriculture à l'inrae
l'Institut national de recherche pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement Aurélie catalog bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi vous êtes
directrice des politiques agricoles et
alimentaires en France à l'hydril
institut du développement durable et des
relations internationales Quentin Le
Guillou bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous
êtes secrétaire général adjoint des
jeunes agriculteurs et vous êtes
agriculteur vous-même plutôt des
céréales c'est ça comme ça orange maïs
dans quelle région à côté 60 km région
parisienne centre Val de Loire sur
l'eure-et-loir-et-vilaine très bien
Emily zappalski évidemment est resté à
mes côtés je vais commencer
en étant le plus basique possible c'est
quoi un pesticide quoi un produit
phytosanitaire de quoi on parle ce soir
dans ce débat Christian oui les
pesticides dans cette catégorie là c'est
les produits issus de la synthèse
chimique qui vont avoir un effet direct
sur des bioagresseurs qui vont les tuer
donc soit des mauvais des insectes des
champignons et qui donc il y a une
pression qui est liée agresseur on
applique un pesticide il a disparu et le
problème est résolu soit normalement on
en a utilisé beaucoup on utilise
beaucoup on a un impact sur le milieu ce
que vous citiez et puis progressivement
l'ensemble de ces murs agresseurs finit
par devenir résistant à certaines des
molécules et donc on empereur donc
effectivement c'est la un peu comme les
antibiotiques c'est la même c'est le
même mécanisme en fait si vous utilisez
beaucoup un produit vous finissez par
avoir des résistances qui émergent et
donc la question elle est votre émission
elle s'appelle peut-on se passer de
pesticides en fait la question c'est ce
dont on est sûr c'est qu'on peut pas se
passer de protection des cultures donc
on est obligé de protéger une culture et
la question c'est par quelle voie est-ce
que c'est
on sort des pesticides on va également
détailler tout ça aurait été le sa
représente quoi dans l'agriculture
française aujourd'hui les pesticides en
proportion c'est l'immense majorité
parce qu'on parle souvent du Bio
on a fait plusieurs émissions sur sur ce
thème c'est encore ultra majoritaire
l'usage des produits phytosanitaires oui
c'est majoritaire on se dit que
l'agriculture biologique ça représente à
peu près 12% de la surface agricole
française donc il est possible que le
les 80 enfin les à peu près 80 % qui
nous reste soit utilisateurs de
pesticides par contre il y a une grande
différence selon la surface agricole
concernée par exemple en prairie on va
avoir très très peu voir pas du tout
d'usage de pesticides là où si on fait
plutôt de la viticulture ou de la grande
culture on va davantage recourir aux
pesticides la question de l'évolution de
de la quantité de pesticides utilisées
en France fait débat parce qu'on n'est
pas tout à fait d'accord sur les
indicateurs auxquels il faut se référer
est-ce que c'est le volume de vente
est-ce que c'est plutôt la quantité de
molécules dangereuses qui est qui est à
comptabilisé ce qui est sûr dans tous
les cas c'est qu'en France on est pour
le moment pas dans les clous des
objectifs qu'on s'est fixés la France a
s'est fixé un objectif ambitieux
de réduction de 50% des pesticides à
horizon 2025 c'est d'ailleurs cinq ans
plus tôt que ce que la Commission
européenne envisage et propose à échelle
européenne et pour le moment on a
vraiment du mal à faire décoller la
baisse des pesticides avec Steve journal
tout à l'heure sur cet objectif 2025
quant à vous vous êtes installé en 2016
c'est ça vous avez pas fait le choix du
bio pour autant comment vous utilisez
les pesticides est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment donc ça nous donne quoi sept
ans de recul de réussir à être je sais
pas un peu plus efficace
à moins utiliser différemment en
fonction des ça alors déjà ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que on l'utilise pas comme
ça bon nous chante on va se lever un
matin et puis on va décider d'aller
pendre partout la plaine donc c'est par
choix on se dit tiens ça y est on est
accompagné on a les BSV du végétal qui
nous dit attention on est dans les pics
de maladie surveillez vos champs donc
c'est des tours de plaine moi quand je
me suis installé j'ai fait le choix de
continuer en conventionnel comme
l'exploitation était avant j'ai plutôt
fait le choix de partir en agriculture
conservation donc en fait je travaille
plus du tout le sol je suis sous couvert
je sais un petit peu plus large mais
rendre blé ce qui me permet meilleur
circulation du vent donc j'ai réussi à
réduire un petit peu les fongicides pour
les maladies donc voilà c'est plein de
petites choses comme ça qu'on essaie et
puis ensuite les moments d'application
on applique pas l'après midi plein vent
sous le soleil on va plutôt faire ça le
matin avec l'hygrométrie ça nous permet
de réduire un peu les doses meilleur
efficacité que ça soit en fongicide ou
en herbicide donc voilà aujourd'hui moi
je reviendrai pas en arrière me dire
aller au bio surtout en fait
malheureusement aujourd'hui où on voit
que la filière bio
pas forcément dans les meilleurs jours
on voit que ben voilà on a de la
conversion de personnes qui vont en bio
mais on a énormément des conversions qui
sont en train d'arriver donc aujourd'hui
c'est comment structurer au mieux cette
filière bio pour essayer que demain le
reste des agriculteurs peut-être arrive
à réduire et ayant bio mais c'est
surtout ces gens-là comme on les
accompagne comme moi peut-être via des
alternatives parce qu'aujourd'hui on
essaye d'interdire ou de limiter les
utilisations mais alternatives arrivent
très tard donc comment on essaye de
jouer avec tout ça alors je voudrais
poser très vite dans ce débat la
question de la santé publique les
pesticides dangereux pour la santé je
vous propose cette étude de l'Inserm
2021 qui dit présomption forte d'un lien
entre l'exposition aux pesticides et ces
pathologies vous allez voir s'afficher
une liste de pathologies qui évidemment
va rendre les plus hippocondriaques de
nos téléspectateurs légèrement effrayés
bon
mais bon voilà ça fait partie des
informations qu'on doit donner il faut
prendre conscience de cette réalité
quand on dit présomption forte Christian
week ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on a démontré qu'il y avait un risque
et quoi il y a un principe de précaution
qui devrait s'appliquer comment vous la
mettez c'est la façon dont ces études
sont faites elles sont faites sur des
très très grandes corps on n'expose pas
délibérément quelqu'un un produit pour
voir comment il se comporte évidemment
donc vous récupérez le le fruit de vous
analyser les pathologies et vous essayez
d'estimer l'ensemble de ce à quoi ils
ont été exposés sur des temps très très
longs ça peut être sur plusieurs
dizaines d'années avant et donc l'étude
de l'insert montre que dans des zones où
l'utilisation d'un certain nombre de
produits est plus forte que dans
d'autres régions on trouve une
surabondance à certains nombre de
pathologies d'où présomption forte
d'accord est-ce que vous ça vous
inquiète vous pour votre santé ou celle
de vos proches parfois le fait
d'utiliser des pesticides c'est la
manière qu'on les utilise aujourd'hui on
pour protéger on a tous les outils en
main du moins entre les protections au
moment où on applique les produits qu'on
les manipule les gants le casque les
combinaisons voilà on essaye tous de se
protéger au mieux du possible parce que
n'importe quel produit qui soit
d'origine
chimiques synthétique synthèse ou même
naturel un litre de cuivre faut pas le
boire comme ça parce que c'est pareil on
va être plutôt malade donc comment on
utilise tous ces produits là de manière
efficace en se protégeant on prend des
gens tout le monde donc c'est au moment
bah s'en vont unigrométrie forte c'est
ce que je disais de manière à ce que le
produit tombe au sol et puis aussi au
niveau de la recherche mécanique via
peut-être soit des alternatives ou
l'utilisation du du de l'engin pour
répondre qu'on appelle le soit un
épandeur de manière à amener au plus
proche le produit pour éviter
tout en vol d'accord Aurélie cataluya
les impacts donc présentation forte sur
la santé humaine mais il y a aussi sur
la biodiversité il faut évidemment
parler de ça tout à fait et on a on a
souvent tendance à se dire bon ben la
galiculture doit faire ça tellement
dangereux et parfois ça semble
extrêmement compliqué ça allait de
répondre à tous ces enjeux que oui
tout à fait et donc on pourrait être
amené à se dire tant pis pour la
biodiversité ça aurait été sympa pour
mon week-end ma balade en vacances mais
c'est pas indispensable en réalité c'est
complètement faux faut vraiment avoir en
tête que la biodiversité c'est une
assurance capacité de production des
sols aujourd'hui et demain par exemple
en 2030 donc avoir en tête les impacts
de des pesticides sur la biodiversité
c'est vraiment comprendre pourquoi
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on est obligé
d'imposer à l'agriculture une réduction
massive des pesticides ça n'est pas pour
venir contrecarrer les pratiques des
agriculteurs c'est vraiment pour se dire
aujourd'hui notre objectif princip
principal ça doit être de maximiser des
agrosystèmes de production aujourd'hui
comme demain
ou 30 ans c'est ça
j'ai l'impression aussi que dans la
société ça évolué la crise covid a aussi
beaucoup fait ça et puis il y a des
mouvements peut-être les jeunes sont
plus sensibles à ces problématiques là
il y a un niveau il y a un seuil
d'acceptabilité de ses produits qui est
un petit peu moins bon que auparavant et
j'ai l'impression qu'on reviendra pas en
arrière pour reprendre vos paroles c'est
à dire que on a plus conscience de
l'impact de ces produits sur la terre
sur l'alimentation sur la santé
forcément mais en même temps si des
injonctions politiques contradictoires
il y a aussi consommateur et un citoyen
qui est un peu schizophrène c'est à dire
qu'il y a il y a un citoyen tout
simplement
mais il regarde son portefeuille et
quand il voit son portefeuille il achète
du conventionnel et c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment il y a un phénomène de
déconversion bio qui s'accentue par
rapport à avant parce que les gens n'ont
plus les moyens du bio mais globalement
si on arrive à avancer tous ensemble on
ira vers plus de bio et juste une chose
je trouve que c'est très intéressant que
les agriculteurs en parlent parce que
quand on parle de pesticides c'est un
peu une caricature de l'agriculteur qui
bousille les terres qui bousillent nos
assiettes parce qu'il veut produire
globalement beaucoup mais quand on
entend des agriculteurs ils font au
mieux ils essaient de cibler énormément
là où ils mettent des pesticides il y a
de plus en plus d'innovations pour aller
au centimètre cube près si j'ai bien
compris pour ne pas en mettre partout et
ça c'est important qu'on ait cette image
là de l'agriculteur qui veille à sa
santé évidemment mais aussi à faire le
mieux possible parce que en effet ils
ont pas toutes les alternatives pour
l'instant trois éléments quand même par
rapport à ça on met on dit toujours s'il
y a pas de pestic c'est bio il y a pas
de pesticides de synthèse on a du cuivre
quand même mais il y a pas de
fertilisant non plus c'est-à-dire on n'a
pas d'engrais azoté de synthèse donc une
partie de la baisse de production ce qui
légitime les prix plus élevés est lié
aussi au fait que cet apport
de fertilité il est plus bas donc faut
en fait faut séparer un peu les choses
et donc
c'est une autre question il faut avoir
plus d'entrées d'engrais organiques et
de faire et de fixation symbolique des
légumineuses mais on met tout le
différentiel de production exclusivement
sur la problématique de protection des
cultures ce qui est pas le cas de ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
effectivement les régulations
biologiques jouent un rôle absolument
considérable donc là restaurer de la
biodiversité c'est récupérer des
régulations biologiques donc ce qui
permet d'avoir une pression avec mes
mots à moi c'est dire quoi laisser
reposer la terre c'est que vous avez en
fait systématiquement des cortèges de
des insectes qui mangent les insectes
ravageurs et donc vous avez une pression
des maladies et une pression des
insectes qui est plus basse et donc vous
aurez naturellement moins besoin de
Pesti par contre ça suppose
effectivement d'avoir de récupérer cette
régulation biologique
idem pour la pour la
la biodiversité du sol la fertilité du
sol elle est liée en l'ensemble des
micro-organismes qu'on a dans le sol
puis le dernier point et c'est dans le
sens de ce que dit disait Quentin tout à
l'heure c'est le fait que effectivement
on passe d'une période où on a été très
dépendant de ces pesticides et il faut
avoir des leviers et offrir aux
agriculteurs des leviers qui sont
efficaces et en fait ce temps de la
recherche il est long
vous quand on parle de produits
phytosanitaires alors là on a fait une
liste de de maladies effrayantes mais
est-ce qu'il y a aussi Où est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir aussi des avantages de leur
usage en termes de santé publique
c'est-à-dire que éviter des maladies de
certaines plantes qui pourraient être
dangereuses pour la santé publique
exactement voilà on voit alors de moins
en moins et on essaye tous d'y veiller
du moins dans les industriels tout le
monde essaye de vraiment gérer au mieux
mais on voit encore des fois de temps en
temps des rappels de produits parce
qu'une graine finalement était
contaminée et détient un champignon et
du coup on se dit attention il est
peut-être dangereux pour la santé
voilà il est avéré donc il y a des
rappels de produits aujourd'hui ils
fongicide qui va aller lutter vraiment
sur la Malaisie de la plante on en est
quasiment ils sont très peu de de
problématiques de de santé derrière
d'une plante qui a qu'à développer
quelque chose qui serait nocif pour la
santé donc
nous interrompre quand on fait du
conventionnel que quand on fait du Bio
ah bah clairement aujourd'hui on
conventionnel étant donné que si
derrière il y a un fongicide qui a
appliqué sur la maladie de la plante
pour aller éventuellement chercher
éviter un charbon donc c'est la graine
qui va qui va devenir noire vient un
traitement de semence ou autre là voilà
là il y a pas de souci aujourd'hui en
bio on pousse peut-être pas encore
suffisamment les recherches mais on voit
qu'il y a des agriculteurs qui essayent
des choses un enrobage à base de
vinaigre ou autre et derrière on arrive
quand même à limiter ces choses là donc
derrière faut bah peut-être accentuer au
maximum la recherche maintenant en
disant on veut en sortir et éviter
peut-être ce qui s'est passé sur les
néoni face aux betteraves ou on s'y
retrouver
dans un passe ça fait 10 ans qu'on
entend parler que il s'abat s’arrêter et
puis finalement c'est arrivé en 2020 que
c'était la catastrophe qu'on a dit on
lance la recherche enfin du moins qu'on
l'a accentué peut-être voilà peut-être
se prendre en avant disant vite vite
trouvons des solutions des alternatives
pour que à un moment donné où on se dit
stop on a une solution en face voilà on
essaye de pas être trop binaire et de
mettre un peu de subtilité dans dans ce
débat on va maintenant se concentrer sur
l'action des pouvoirs publics parce que
si on se dit comment se passait des
pesticides autour de cette table est
d'accord pour dire essayons de trouver
la solution mais bon c'est ça prend du
temps et c'est pas si ça on va se
concentrer sur l'action des pouvoirs
publics grâce à Steve Jourdain qui va
nous rejoindre tout de suite puisque
rebonsoir Steve le gouvernement a
annoncé on l'évoquait rapidement tout à
l'heure un plan pour réduire cette
utilisation de produits phytosanitaire
un nouveau plan car c'est le troisième
depuis 2008 il y a eu le plan écofito 1
sous Nicolas Sarkozy l'objectif était de
diminuer de 50% en 10 ans l'utilisation
des pesticides à travers notamment un
grand programme de subvention aux
agriculteurs il a eu ensuite le plan
Écophyto 2 c'était en 2015 il s'agissait
alors de repousser l'objectif des 50% à
2025 et au mois de février le
gouvernement borne a donc annoncé un
nouveau plan c'est Emmanuel Macron qui
en a présenté la philosophie écoutez
c'était au salon de l'agriculture
on a réduit très fortement nos
pesticides on va encore continuer de
le faire mais on peut pas le faire
à culades à coup d'interpellation et de
silence qu'on oppose en disant on va
tous mourir il y a des rapports
scientifiques ils sont là on les connaît
on les prend en compte mais il y a des
pratiques à changer et faire changer une
société
c'est pas simplement interpeller les
gens les insulter ou avoir des actions
radicales alors essayez d'être concret
que prévoit le gouvernement en matière
de pesticides très très bonne question
Thomas pour le moment on a très peu de
détails sur les mesures qui vont être
annoncées car le plan est toujours en
discussion dit-on au sein des ministères
ce qu'on sait c'est que sur les 500
pesticides commercialisés en Europe 250
doivent faire l'objet d'une réévaluation
dans les trois ans à venir les retraits
de produits vont se multiplier cela aura
des conséquences très concrètes pour nos
agriculteurs le gouvernement promet de
les soutenir dans cette transition il
présentera une feuille de route d'ici à
l'été une enveloppe sera débloquée pour
mettre en musique la stratégie de
l'exécutif mais l'objectif est clair pas
de nouvelles interdiction sans
alternative écouter Marc féno c'était au
salon de l'agriculture encore une fois
au mois de février écoutez certains
nombre de gens qui sont la place
publique disent Yaka faucon c'est simple
suffit d'interdire comme si
l'interdiction entre produisait la
solution l'interdiction n'a jamais
produit la solution et donc on a besoin
de travailler dans une forme de
planification à anticiper ce que peuvent
être risque de disparition de molécules
à regarder toujours dans la chimie et
les produits phytosanitaires qu'elles
peuvent être les alternatives les autres
alternatives éventuellement les
alternatives l'inrae travaillent
précisément dessus l'Institut national
de recherche pour l'agriculture estime
dans un rapport qu'il est possible de
sortir des pesticides chimiques d'ici à
2050 de conditions notamment à cela des
politiques publiques fortes et
coordonnées et la transformation de la
pacte la politique agricole commune qui
est décidée au niveau européen au rythme
ouvrant les choses Thomas la faire sans
plutôt mal embarquer merci Steve on va
justement poser la question tout de
suite à Christian huile puisque vous
êtes le directeur scientifique
agriculture de de cette institut ce plan
disait forte volonté politique et
peut-être qu'il faut insister européenne
peut-être le plus important dans la
phrase qu'est-ce que vous en dites
plusieurs composants dans les scénarios
qu'on a proposé qu'on a construit qui
sont des scénarios narratifs c'est pas
des prescriptifs
il faut vraiment booster la recherche
sur la protection des cultures et donc
explorer des champs totalement nouveaux
autour de l'immunité végétale autour du
microbiote des plantes autour des
régulations par les par les paysages
olfactifs donc on change le comportement
des insectes pour ça doit répondre en
fait aussi à une évolution de la
consommation
et donc avec à la fois une alimentation
des filières longues et des filières
courtes et il y aura pas de modification
de ce que les agriculteurs peuvent
produire y compris en diversifiant leurs
production si on n'a pas une une
adéquation à la consommation
il faut des politiques de transition
transition dans les territoires et ce
qui en fait encadre ces politiques de
transition c'est les politiques globales
dont effectivement l'impact la politique
agricole commune
en quelque sorte c'est à dire où est-ce
qu'on commence quand même à
apprendre en compte la demande de des
consommateurs et l'urgence
environnementale dans la politique
agricole commune qui vient de démarrer
la celle au 1er janvier 2023 pour la
période 2023 2027 il y a de légères
inflexions des paiements pour services
environnementaux dans le concept est
introduit des différentes éléments de
conditionnalités mais clairement avec
cette trajectoire là on n'atteint pas
l'objectif qui est donné de -50 % des
pesticides en 2000 en 2030 selon le
pacte européen donc il faut à la fois
aller dans cette dans cette direction là
et accélérer la transition et donc
l'accélération de la transition c'est n
levier qui sont qui sont mis en même
temps mais cet objectif il est il est
atteignable objectivement d'accord c'est
faisable c'est faisable vous dites mais
ça suppose peut-être et là c'est une
question qui nous concerne tous vous qui
nous regardez nous autour de la table la
question de nos comportements
alimentaires ça pourra pas marcher si
quoi si on consomme autant de
de viande de de produits enfin voilà
parce que il faut rappeler que une large
part de la l'évolution de l'agriculture
sert à nourrir les animaux que nous on
mange après simplifie un peu mais c'est
quand même ça
en fait on peut pas demander aux
agriculteurs de porter avec tout seul la
transition sur pesticides d'une part et
on peut pas penser la transition sans
pesticide sans penser une transition
plus large de l'ensemble de notre
système alimentaire pourquoi et
notamment parce que comme vous l'avez
évoqué aujourd'hui on a à peu près 65%
de la surface agricole française qui
sert à nourrir les animaux d'élevage
français à ça on ajoute 20% de la
surface agricole française qui part à
l'export et donc il nous reste
finalement une très faible part qui sert
à l'alimentation des Français direct et
dans une moindre mesure à des usages non
alimentaires comme par exemple la
production d'énergie donc si demain on
dit aux agriculteurs vous allez réduire
drastiquement l'utilisation de
pesticides une des conséquences dans
certains endroits en tout cas ça va être
une réduction légère à minima des
volumes de production or on ne veut
probablement pas réduire la part de ce
qui de la production française qui va
servir à nourrir les Français donc on
n'a pas marge manoeuvre il va falloir
réduire probablement soit ce qui paraît
l'export soit ou c'est pas
contradictoire la part de la production
végétale française qui sert à nourrir
nos animaux d'élevage donc oui quand on
parle pesticide on peut on doit faire le
lien jusqu'à la consommation de viande
et votre avis sur les politiques
publiques c'est est-ce que on continue
de subventionner des exploitations de
plus en plus grandes ce qui est pas très
cohérent avec l'objectif de
d'une agriculture plus verte il y a bien
une petite partie de la des politiques
agricoles françaises ou européennes en
lien avec la politique agricole commune
qui aide qui accompagne les agriculteurs
dans la réduction des pesticides mais
pour reprendre l'exemple de la PAC les
meilleures mesures pour faire ça c'est
soit la conversion à l'agriculture
biologique là c'est on passe à zéro
pesticide chimique soit ce qu'on appelle
des mesures agro-environnementales qui a
représentent un contrat de 5 ans pendant
lequel on va rémunérer l'agriculteur et
à l'issue duquel ils s'engagent à avoir
amélioré ces pratiques mental en
respectant un cahier des charges le
problème c'est que ces deux mesures là
elles représentent a L2 moins de 4% du
budget total de la politique agricole
commune et le gros l'énorme majorité des
subventions publiques continuent non pas
évidemment à subventionner directement
l'utilisation des pesticides mais
continuationner une orientation agricole
un modèle agricole qui qui pousse les
agriculteurs à continuer à utiliser des
pesticides donc on a une vraie
dichotomie entre on a une toute petite
partie des subventions qui aident et qui
va dans le bon sens et une majorité des
subventions qui n'aident pas les
agriculteurs à penser à un changement de
système alors vous voudriez bien aller
plus vite mais vous nous dites quoi ce
que vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure il
y a pour l'instant j'ai pas
d'alternative c'est ça dans de nombreux
cas pour l'instant les alternatives sont
pas forcément là où ont du mal à arriver
c'est surtout que surtout ça en fait ça
va être la concurrence et demain je vais
reprendre un petit peu ce qui vient
d'être dit mais demain si on veut sortir
de tout ça et se dire tout le monde
passe en bio donc on réduit
l'alimentation
au bétail et du coup alors c'est quoi
c'est du coup on dit à des exploitants
en élevage bon bah vous arrêtez ou vous
retournez voilà donc bon pourquoi pas
qui paye comment vont passer un
accompagnement bon voilà après on est
content d'aller skier sur des belles
pistes bien tondues par des par des
vaches ou des moutons l'hiver mais ah
bon faut trouver des alternatives c'est
surtout que les derniers qui vont rester
est-ce qu'on est sûr du coup qu'on va
bien les nourrir avec notre aliment
français et non pas du maïs brésilien ou
ou qui vient de si demain ça réouvre
russe ou je ne sais de d'autres pays
donc on demande d'essayer de bien
produire mais on a une concurrence
européenne qui est là déjà aujourd'hui
le bio européen n'est pas forcément le
même dans chaque pays donc déjà
peut-être harmoniser toute l'Europe pour
avoir une pack ensemble et forte et
efficace et puis bah au niveau des
importations étrangers bien contrôler ce
qui rentre en France parce qu'on peut
essayer de produire vers mais si ça
arrive noir d'extérieur alors justement
je voudrais on va ouvrir ce chapitre
parce que et on va utiliser deux
témoignages de de d'agriculteurs qui
étaient dans des manifestations
parisiennes pour défendre leur métier
qui tiennent à peu près le même discours
que que vous ils disent attention à une
forme de concurrence déloyale même au
sein de l'Union européenne écoutant
on a une totale incompréhension de ce
qui se décide puisque de toute façon on
a l'impression que tout est fait pour
nuire à l'agriculture et à la
souveraineté alimentaire à côté de ça on
importe des produits qui ne respectent
pas du tout nos normes qui sont faits
par des méthodes complètement interdites
chez nous sur certaines filières comme
la betterave il nous faut encore deux
trois ans de recherche c'est en bonne
voie mais il nous manque clairement du
temps et là c'est vraiment le coup près
de cette interdiction d'utiliser les
néonicotinoïdes par exemple mais dans
d'autres filières on a supprimé les
produits et donc par exemple les cerises
j'ai des collègues qui arrachent des
cerisiers et les cerises turques
arrivent en France parce que eux on leur
a pas interdit produit alors là il nous
parle des cerise turques quand un lieu
je sais pas s'il y a une liste des des
produits où vous jugez que la
concurrence est déloyale ah bah sur
majorité des produits aujourd'hui fait
en France que ça soit les cerises bah
les betteraves on en parlait les
betteraves l'Allemagne autorise
l'épandage en plein
[Musique]
également comme après les produits
moches les fruits moches un fruit même
s'il a un peu tordu ça reste un fruit et
ça c'est c'est quelque chose qui va
falloir réapprendre nous tous français
alors on va parler du misolle
agriculture dans un coin 100 mais je
devrais vous entendre sur cette question
de concurrence déloyale quand même et de
d'harmonisation ou de manque
d'harmonisation des règles européens si
on regarde l'échelle européenne
factuellement la France c'est pas le
pays qui en a le moins de produits
phytos
parmi les 500 qui étaient cités et on
est le deuxième pays en nombre donc on
en a on en utilise beaucoup mais
effectivement il peut y avoir des
distorsions entre entre pays sur
certaines homologations et nous ce que
ce que disait la première ministre au
salon de l'agriculture c'est d'aller
vers plus d'Europe donc
réussir à avoir une vraie trajectoire
européenne aujourd'hui on travaille dans
le cadre d'une directive ce qui permet
d'avoir des déclinaisons différentes
entre pays européens et il y a sur la
table et qui fait beaucoup beaucoup de
débats l'objectif d'un règlement ce qui
fait qu'il y a peu de différence il y a
plus de différence entre les pays et
avec un règlement qui donne un objectif
par contre extrêmement ambitieux de
moins 50% d'un indicateur qui est un peu
complexe et donc je vous rassemblé voilà
l'économie ici donc ça c'est au sein de
l'Europe mais effectivement ça n'empêche
pas ce qui peut arriver de l'extérieur
de l'Europe où il faut avoir une vraie
vigilance et donc jouer sur la
traçabilité mais ça existe un des
barrières douanières non tarifaires qui
permettent d'avoir une vigilance sur des
modes de production dont on ne veut pas
et ça suppose effectivement d'avoir une
réflexion et encore une fois ça engage
le choix de l'ensemble des acteurs
autour de cette transition c'est une
vraie transition qu'il faut entreprendre
avec ambition alors comme promis gros
plan maintenant grâce à vous Emilie sur
Marc feno le ministre de l'Agriculture
entre le respect de l'environnement et
le rendement il a quoi un peu de mal à
choisir oui son cœur balance
environnement ou rendement c'est ainsi
qu'on pourrait résumer un petit peu les
états d'âme de notre ministre de
l'Agriculture Marc fenault sur ces
sujets des pesticides alors si on prend
l'exemple qui était indiqué tout à
l'heure dans le reportage du S métaux la
clore j'ai admirer la façon que vous
aviez de le prononcer d'ailleurs je sais
pas si je réussirai une seconde fois
mais bon en tout cas sur sur la base des
avis scientifiques l'Agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire de l'alimentation de
l'environnement et du travail voulait
l'interdire en tout cas avait commencé
toute une procédure pour l'interdire
alors qu'au niveau de l'Union européenne
pour le moment il est autorisé et cela a
priori jusqu'en novembre 2024 donc
l'idée c'était d'anticiper un petit peu
cette décision ça a pas du tout plu au
ministre de l'Agriculture qui s'en
émêlée et s'en est suivi une sorte de
bras de fer en fait entre l'agence et le
ministre le ministre a tenté d'aller à
l'encontre de cette procédure
d'interdiction demandant à l'agence de
revoir sa copie
à poser correctement le débat et à
changer de méthode pour avancer on peut
lire ça sur un tweet qu'il a indiqué il
a noté exactement ça tout en publiant la
lettre qui l'avait fait parvenir à
l'agence pour valider son choix enfin en
tout cas lui demander de revoir sa
copine alors peine perdue l'agence n'a
pas voulu répondre à cette demande qui
était plutôt de l'ordre politique alors
qu'elle se situe sur le niveau
scientifique et à la statuer le 20 avril
sur l'interdiction de ce produit donc on
pourrait dire un point pour
l'environnement zéro point pour le
rendement qui est parti en croisade pour
défendre une autre molécule alors oui
nouvelle tentative et cette fois-ci
réussi sur la fausse fine cette fois-ci
alors c'est un insecticide crucial pour
le blé l'orge et d'autres céréales est
très important pour nos exportations
notamment vers l'Afrique donc il y a de
l'argent en jeu son interdiction devrait
devait intervenir aujourd'hui même
décider par cette même agence de
sécurité sanitaire une fois encore donc
le ministre a demandé à l'agence de
évaluer ces décisions
mais elle a été et elle a été actée le
elle a acté le 20 avril sur la poursuite
de son utilisation c'est à dire que
cette fois-ci c'est pas drôle mais c'est
pas drôle mais on peut dire équilibre
puisque elle a cédé finalement aussi
reine politique mais c'est difficile
quand même de voir cette agence qui est
censé être indépendante c'est un
établissement public indépendant plié
sur ces injonctions du pouvoir politique
et plus globalement c'est quand même
assez difficile de comprendre cette
prise de position les deux herbicides
étant pour le moment autorisé en Europe
donc on en interdit un on garde l'autre
on a une sorte de deux poids de mesure
qu'on ne comprend pas très bien pourquoi
ces interférences de la part du ministre
de l'Agriculture on peut comprendre
forcément et on en a parlé un
désinquiétudes du ministre c'est une
profession qui est en proie des
difficultés quand même croissantes vous
en avez cité certaines on peut en
rajouter l'année de diminution du nombre
d'exploitations la gribashing aussi les
rendements difficiles la souveraineté
alimentaire aussi qui est en perte une
vitesse juste pour prendre un exemple
nos maraîchers ils sont capables de
fournir 60% des légumes qui sont
consommés en France 40% pour les fruits
donc c'est pas forcément suffisant en
tout cas on aurait des ambitions
supérieures et ce sujet de la
souveraineté alimentaire il est revenu
au devant de la scène avec la crise
covid et puis avec la guerre en Ukraine
on termine sur cette question comment
réussir ce pari alors pour transformer
en profondeur les modèles agricoles tout
en assurant le rendement faudrait
investir massivement pour changer les
pratiques pour aussi accentuer la
recherche pour se donner du temps et pas
être au pied du mur histoire de pas
laisser aussi les agriculteurs qui sont
déjà en mal de revenus assumer seul
cette transition délicate mais en fait
cette croisade du ministre contre les
décisions de l'agence mais ça donne pas
tellement de signaux très positifs ou en
tout cas compréhensible sur la direction
qui est envisagée alors il passe il est
pas sûr que la loi d'orientation
agricole qui est portée par ce même
marque feno et qui doit avoir le jour
d'ici la fin de l'année porte des
réponses beaucoup plus claires sur le
sujet merci beaucoup et militia une
question très précise je découvre
l'existence de la fausse fine je
connaissais pas assez donc que vous
devez utiliser puisque vous produisez
des céréales directement en fait la
fausse fine c'est
fluidification fumigène qui est mis dans
les dans les bateaux au moment de avant
que les céréales soient chargés dans les
bateaux l'exportation
en fait là où il a tourné un petit peu
monsieur féno c'était plutôt en disant
attention si il y a plus on perd les
marchés d'exportation nous on fait parce
que les pays qui importent bah nous le
demande de le faire parce que souvent
majorité de ces bateaux là partent
beaucoup pour l'Afrique donc un climat
quand même différent d'une autre
peut-être avec des variations de
température et des fois des zygrométries
supérieures donc à risque d'avoir en
plus bah du coup des insectes en plus
dans les bateaux ou qui viennent
détruire
les céréales une fois arrivé à Port donc
voilà il fallait pour un enjeu de santé
et puis de respect de ces pays-là de
continuer nous la crainte c'était que si
demain ça se fermait et bah c'était des
marchés qui disparaissaient pour la
ferme France et là à quel coup voilà on
savait qu'on allait perdre sûrement un
prix de vente des céréales donc tout de
suite c'était impacté nous agriculteurs
et là encore c'était compliqué au début
je repose la question qui est presque un
peu la question générale d'un débat
comme celui-là si on se projette au lit
Catalo en
2050 donc j'ai vérifié les prévisions
démographiques on dit 9 milliards 700
millions d'humains pas loin de 10
milliards en 2050 est-ce qu'on pourra
nourrir cette population sans pesticides
il y a plusieurs travaux scientifiques
de prospective qui nous disent que oui
on peut mais certainement pas de manière
facile et certainement pas on ne faisant
que des petits changements
d'optimisation à un endroit en fait
comme je le disais tout à l'heure c'est
vraiment une transition globale du
système exactement qui nous faut donc
prenons l'exemple de de nos agriculteurs
français à qui on demande une transition
vers son pesticides ou en tout cas une
réduction massive de pesticides
aujourd'hui on connaît des Sony des
solutions agronomiques pour pouvoir
faire avec beaucoup beaucoup moins de
pesticides ça suppose par exemple de
rallonger les rotations donc de faire
plus de culture différente très bien
mais aujourd'hui il y a ces nouvelles
cultures que les agriculteurs pourraient
être amenés à faire dans ce cas là qui
n'ont pas de déboucher viable
économiquement viable pour les
agriculteurs et par exemple si on
voulait si on veut se passer
d'herbicides on pourrait implanter du
sorgho qui est à la capacité à bien
étouffer les mauvaises herbes ou les
potentiels mauvaises herbes sur le sol
mais aujourd'hui
ou alors ça peut être le cas du chanvre
aussi le chanvre est très bon pour
étouffer mais ce sont des filières qui
sont aujourd'hui beaucoup moins
rémunératrices et beaucoup moins
structuré qu'une filière colza par
exemple en France donc l'agriculteur
aujourd'hui il a pas envie de produire
du chanvre alors qu'il pourrait beaucoup
plus sécuriser son revenu s'ils
produisait autre chose donc cet exemple
là il nous montre que on peut pas penser
la transition vers moins de pesticides
en faisant porter uniquement l'effort et
même l'accompagnement politique au
niveau des exploitations agricoles il va
falloir impliquer l'ensemble de la
filière et il va falloir réinvestir sur
de la structuration de filière qui vont
nous permettre d'avoir une plus grande
diversité de culture Christian oui
qu'est-ce que la technologie permet de
d'offrir comme perspective un peu
positive dans un débat comme celui-là
dans une autre émission de télévision je
sais pas si vous l'utilisez mais je
parlais des insecticides qui sont
utilisés dans les silos à grains et
notamment le fait de connecter les silos
à grains permet d'évaluer la température
et donc de de mieux ventiler et
d'utiliser moins de d'insecticides dans
ces silos gras bon là on est vraiment
dans la data ou la ou le ou les objets
connectés au service de d'une réduction
de des insecticides est-ce que la
technologie peut je suis pas
voilà persuadé que la télécologie va
nous sauver et va trouver les solutions
à tous nos problèmes mais est-ce que
c'est une piste importante il y a
énormément d'innovations technologiques
il y a des innovations
organisationnelles et il y a des
innovations technologiques vous avez
mentionné effectivement c'est détecteurs
de dans les silos pour mesurer la
température on peut aussi d'ailleurs
mesurer la présence d'insectes
uniquement au bruit et donc d'intervenir
au bon moment si la température est trop
élevée on peut on peut la baisser s'il y
a des risques d'insectes on peut il y a
d'autres méthodes d'intervention que
mettre des insecticides mais il y a
beaucoup de choses les problématiques de
désherbage vous aviez une démonstration
et une illustration en agriculteur en
agriculture biologique avec des machines
mais ce qui avait comme machine c'est
des bineuses et des systèmes à eau
rotatives relativement enfin qui sont
aujourd'hui sur le marché mais il y a
des choses totalement nouvelles qui sont
en train de se développer et qui sont
accessibles déjà c'est des bineuses avec
détection des adventices par capteur
photographie et analyse d'image par
intelligence artificielle ce qui permet
à la bineuse non pas d'aller de façon
totalement droite et uniquement entre
les rangs mais entre les plantes sur le
rang avec des petits couteaux qui vont à
toute vitesse et donc ce sont des
techniques qui sont émergentes alors
avec toujours cette question tant que le
marché est occupé par les herbes il y a
pas de place pour cette technologie là
donc on est dans cette période de
transition je mentionnais tout à l'heure
le microbiote qui est une énorme
découverte on a il y a un microbiote
autour des plantes qui protègent la
plante et que donc au lieu qu'une plante
saine soit une plante sur lequel il y a
rien dans la réalité une plante selle
c'est une plante sur laquelle il y a un
écosystème de bactéries de de
champignons de levure qui sont en état
d'équilibre et donc la question qu'on se
pose c'est est-ce qu'on peut apporter ce
microbiote pour stabiliser la plante ce
qui permettrait aussi de la nourrir avec
ce qu'on apporterait au niveau du sol et
puis on peut réguler des champignons en
modifiant les paysages olfactifs donc on
le on le fait déjà aujourd'hui sur le
carpocap sont mentionné tout à l'heure
la pomme il y a un verre qui fait des
trous dans les pommes et donc on peut
empêcher ce papillon devenir et de
pondre en modifiant le paysage olfactif
on sature avec des hormones sexuelles ce
qui fait qu'il y a plus une reproduction
mais on peut aussi modifier le réduire
l'arrivée des insectes sur une plante en
lui mettant une fête une barrière
d'odeur donc il est perdu et donc en
fait c'est il y a des tas de levier la
vraie difficulté elle est d'abord de les
amener à des niveaux de maturité
technologiques qu'il amène au marché et
puis le prix à payer de l'utilisation de
ça c'est sans doute beaucoup plus de
complexité mais si on veut qu'il soit
efficace il va falloir dans tous les cas
faire baisser la pression devant donc
c'est un peu un changement de façon de
concevoir au lieu de systématiquement
quel que soit la pression on arrive à le
supprimer il faut d'abord faire baisser
la pression donc faire de la prophylaxie
et ensuite utiliser une batterie de
système on peut dire c'est complexe mais
dès qu'on a appris à faire quelque chose
dès qu'on a les bons outils d'aide à la
décision
et elle a juste rémunération à ce moment
là la transition est possible un tout
dernier mot Emilie rapide je trouve que
ce qui est un peu révoltant c'est que
finalement on a l'impression que des
agriculteurs engagés peuvent aller vers
ça parce qu'il y a pas de il y a pas de
retour positif à s'engager là-dedans
vous dites c'est plus long c'est plus
complexe c'est éventuellement des
investissements et finalement le bio où
ces choses là ça coûte plus cher donc
les rendements et le retour financier il
est beaucoup plus moins important c'est
à dire qu'il y a pas de gain bio par
rapport à ce qu'on peut investir il y a
pas de d'incitation dernier mot pour
vous quantième est-ce que est-ce qu'il y
a un retour sur investissement sur la
partie technologique quand même parce
que ce sont des investissements
importants aujourd'hui on a plein de
choses qui sont en train de sortir
toutes ces systèmes robotiques et autres
ça coûte cher donc c'est là derrière
l'amortissement pour sortir tout ça à
quel coût sur quelle durée et quand on a
des fois des marchés agricoles bah qu'on
a connu malheureusement avec la guerre
très très océan comment le langage sur
l'avenir c'est vraiment très compliqué
mais après oui des choses existent on le
voit sur des réductions
d'applications d'engrais chimiques voilà
aujourd'hui on fait des cartographies
satellites qui nous dit il faut en
mettre un peu moins donc ça c'est des
choses assez simples et efficaces qui
fonctionnent merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat et à
bientôt sur sur Public Sénat je vous dis
à demain pour un nouveau sens publique
vous pouvez également retrouver notre
émission en replay et puis toutes les
émissions de la chaîne documentaire y
compris évidemment sur notre nouvelle
plateforme public sénat.fr allez il fait
un tour tout de suite vous verrez c'est
super belle soirée
[Musique]